okay well thank you very much it's it's
a great privilege to be able to speak to
this audience in this venue so I'm going
to given the time of day and the time of
the week I'm going to be talking about
some mathematical models but I'm not
going to be doing any mathematics in the
talk I'll point you to places where
things are written up but I want to tell
you about just a couple of actually
completely different mathematical models
I've been interested in over the last
few years which attempt to cast light on
how senescence how aging evolves and so
these are just two of very many and they
come at it from very different angles so
I'd like to I'd like to bring across a
few a few points so i think that the
evolution of senescence can't be
analyzed without seriously incorporating
epistasis which is something that for
good reasons people like to avoid it in
modeling without incorporating
randomness and this is randomness on
many levels randomness of life spans
obviously randomness of genotypes so not
just average genotypes but you know and
average phenotypes coming from the
genotypes but and also randomness of
environments and these all interact in
sometimes unpredictable ways and I'd
also like to at least try to convince
you of the point that all evolution is
evolution of senescence in the sense
that while we it's common to ignore age
structure in modeling evolution think
about you know the evolution of
organisms that are sort of
point objects which appear and disappear
in fact all fitness relevant mutations
must involve changes which take place
across a life course and to the extent
that the that effect in time actually
produces non-trivial effects it's
something that we can't ignore and I'm
going to hoping to convince you that in
fact the it often often does produce
effects that we that we shouldn't ignore
so to begin with what is what are the
questions to which an evolutionary
theory of aging could be part of the
answer that's to say why do we need an
evolutionary theory of aging so one
question is why are organisms allowed to
fall apart after being painstakingly
built up okay so there's a tremendous
amount of resources invested in building
up complex organisms and then at the
point where they reach maturity that
process goes into reverse and second
given that substantially longer life is
possible in many organisms which we know
we know there are there are point
mutations which show up in in C elegans
and yeast and various even somewhat more
complex organisms why are these not
prevalent in other words in the you know
words of the original cartoon why isn't
why isn't what what's wrong with living
forever and this was well stated by
biologist George Williams who provided
one of the earliest to 1950s arguments
about the nature of evolution of
senescence says it is indeed remarkable
that after a seemingly miraculous feat
of morphogenesis a complex mezzo and
should be unable to perform the much
simpler task of merely maintaining what
is
already formed and so these are two
different questions and the answers
might not be the same and they might not
even be compatible with each other so I
like to think of question one is asking
why does optimality fail so why is the
wire organisms why are organisms not as
good actually I've got these in the
wrong order let's question to it anyway
why why are organisms not as good as
they could be in some certain sins and
the second question is why is longer
life or potential immortality not
optimal you know to these are the right
order everyone and the the usual
framework that people use for thinking
about these questions originally goes
back to an idea that was stated among
other less cogent ideas by Vice men in
the 19th century and was then given new
life by medawar and Williams in the
1950s which is that late acting dilet
arias mutations are subject to less
stringent selection control so the basic
idea here is so this has been stated in
in different forms one form is to say
that well billet arias mutations are
going to be arising and many of them
will have their effects primarily on you
know cause an individual to have health
problems or be more likely to die at one
age rather than another there'll be some
profile of effects on the individual
mortality curve of the individual who
who acquires this mutant allele and that
if the age at which it has its effect is
late in life then there is it's going
there's gonna be very little selection
pressure to weed it out of the
population so you'd expect the
population to acquire many of these late
acting deleterious alleles and real
a few of the early acting ones this is
often called the mutation accumulation
theory of aging a related theory which
is the version that medawar promoted was
was sometimes called antagonistic
pleiotropy which is which argues rather
that there might be you might imagine
there are mutations which have slightly
positive effects at one age and slightly
negative effects at another age and if
the positive effects come early and the
negative effects come late then that
will be a net gain and so the optimal so
that's more an optimality argument that
the the optimal organism will tend to be
one that has that takes its benefits
early and and takes the the harmful
effects late so okay so the first the
first part of my talk is going to be
about theory of mutation accumulation
this is joint work with Steve Evans and
Ken wachter and I'm just going to give a
broad brush presentation of well what
the what the problem is and the the bit
that we've tried to contribute to it so
well sorry actually this sort of should
have come before I got the wrong order
so I was going to say that they're more
questions that we'd hoped to address
with theory why does some organisms not
siness it's common but not Universal for
organisms have increased mortality and
decreased fertility with age why do
mortality rates show characteristic
patterns so these are mortality rates
happen to be from from Canada which
showed characteristic early high
mortality rapid drop then an adolescent
fast rise and then this peculiar so
on a log scale so this is an exponential
increase in mortality called the the
gompertz pattern and then a late-life
plateau and mortality so I'm not going
to have much to say about about this
pattern today but this is in what a lot
of research on the biology and evolution
of mortality is ultimately hoping to
understand why we see this pattern not
just in humans but similar patterns in
many different organisms so okay so now
yeah and and then a question that I will
talk more about is if you believe the
antagonistic pleiotropy story so it
should be beneficial to take your games
early why does this tent not tend to run
to to an extreme there are organisms
where that does seem to happen but why
does it not why do we not see it as the
generic pattern in nature that organisms
you know reproduce as fast as possible
and die and die immediately after and
I'm going to talk about this with regard
to the problem of diapause so of
organisms that seem to intentionally
delay their their growth so okay so many
of you are familiar with the general
idea of mutation selection equilibrium
so we have a mildly dilla terious
mutation a frequency piece of tea at
time T arising constantly a trait new
and the and so we have this you tend
have an equilibrium frequency of about
new over s where so s is the the
selective cost and new is the rate at
which it arises and our work on on this
started with an interesting argument put
forward by brian charles worth in 2001
so he he suggested that well if we
imagine that
is a constant reproduction rate and a
high background mortality mu and that
mutation increases mortality that we
have a lot of mutations potentially each
one of which each of which a raw raises
mortality at some fixed age by a fixed
amount and in a constant mutation rate
across these across all the ages of at
which these mutations could have their
effect cases if you just accept all
those those assumptions then you get to
a striking conclusion that the so the
cost of a mutate of a mutation that acts
at age x is essential is the loss if you
think of it as being the lost
reproduction well on average your
remaining lifespan at age age x would be
e to the minus mu X the probability you
would still be alive to experience
effect of that mutation so if you put
this into that formula then you get the
equilibrium frequency of mutations
acting at a gem is like increases like e
to the MU X so you get this exponential
increase which oddly sounds a lot like
the the gompertz pattern right
exponential increase in mortality rates
with age now um the the problem is that
this is a this is an argument about
single a single locus so how do you this
is this is implicitly now being applied
to you know infinitely many low sigh so
the question is is the difference
between you know is there a difference
that really matters right does it
doesn't actually make sense to apply
this and would you expect qualitatively
similar results so the standard way of
extending this story to multiple sites
is
the Camorra murayama model which sees
the witch so is a explicitly a non non
epistatic model and well anyway so you
have a passo number of mutations and the
and then there's this fitness cost to
each one that you have of the same s and
you end up with a very similar story but
this depends very much on there being no
interaction between the effects of
mutations now the problem is that there
is no way to coherently describe this as
a non epistatic story so and this is I
think a very interesting point because
one problem that we often have in trying
to model at the stasis is on a
mathematical in a mathematical framework
is that there's only one way to be non
epistatic but there are lots of ways of
being at the static your if big it there
becomes a question how do you pick the
right model the one which has the right
properties and so there is a very
natural sort of epistasis which is
unavoidable when you're talking about
the evolution of demographic structures
the which essentially comes from the
fact that an organism can only die once
so a mutation that will kill you you
know at age 50 together with a mutation
that will kill you at age 40 is not does
not have the some of the costs of those
two right so the end the end that's not
a problem if the the effects of
mutations remain small right and this is
a story about small effect mutation so
it sounds like we're all right except
the whole premise of this is that even
while individual mutation effects are
small they're going to keep accumulating
until they become large okay so there's
no way to avoid right in the whole story
here is that at some point you get to an
equilibrium with
mutations have accumulated to the point
that they drastically changed the
mortality curve and so there's actually
no way to avoid having a deal looking at
that's that sort of epistasis okay the
end now we're going to going to model it
and we're going to treat it in the
simplest possible way and then we're
going to think of mutations as having
mortality effects which ad but if the
mortality effects add then selectively
costs are concave right the effect of
get putting two different mutations
together is less than the effect than
the sum of the the cost of having of
having each of them so we're in our
model we use the net reproductive
reproduction ratio or net reproduction
rate as it's sometimes called and
demography which essentially since we'll
be thinking of ours being equal to one
ours the population growth rate
essentially it's the the the net number
of offspring produced by an individual
with that who has a particular genotype
oh it's sr r equals your ideas are equal
zero it's and although well we it it may
actually be that there's an argument for
looking at the log of the net
reproductive rate but I won't get into
that right now so okay so we've got this
problem of applying in in the the
Charles worth work applying the single
locus model to an infinite locus setting
and we have the non a nativity we also
have that mutations which act only at
one age are extremely unrealistic we
don't know we don't yet still don't have
any real image of what the mortality
profile of a naturally occurring dilla
Tereus mutation might be here's from the
one study by Pletcher and kurt's
that actually could get out this in
drosophila so anyway you see there you
have non-constant effect it's a
mortality effects over age of particular
occurring in particular lines they're
non constant with age they have some
somewhat complicated profiles in case we
want to have a model which could would
allow us to incorporate all this so now
so we have the linear version of
Hamilton formula where all right so for
thinking of net reproduction ratio this
is survival of sort of the the wild type
and the the cost of a the cost of a of a
of a mutation which kills you at which
see so kills you an aged a it's bright
it's going to be the what you've lost by
dying at AJ and we could replace this
with a nonlinear version right we're
essentially the the the lost survival
comes back in to the denominator and
well so and that's sort of what we're
doing but we're we want to so we needed
a mathematical framework where this
could actually be analyzed to what we
ended up with was a very abstract model
of the genome where there's a space of
potential mutations in the charles worth
picture this is can be thought of as the
positive realign mutations correspond to
ages of effect but you can think of them
as being sort of linear on chromosomes
in some way this can be
and a pretty pretty arbitrary metric
space actually doesn't metric except for
some some things it needs to be but
mutation rate new which is a actually so
I say Sigma fine I'd measure although
for much of what some of what we do it
needs to be a finite measure there's a
genotype space which are integer
measures so on am so essentially
elements subsets of em potentially with
with duplication and the state of a
system the system is a probability on
genotypes and then we have a fairly
arbitrary selection cost assigned to
each genotype each collection of
mutations that that someone could have
and the we are assuming only that this
that all mutations ardilla terious this
is an increasing function so if you add
an extra mutation in that then s doesn't
go down and and that it's Lipschitz so
the effect of any individual mutation is
is bounded by a constant ok so the
analog of the usual evolution equation
for mutation selection equilibrium
becomes this which we can understand as
voices
and things is your first up okay
try that again
we just have a deleterious mutation yes
something like that yes
so okay there we are so okay so we have
one term corresponding to change due to
adding a new random mutation like which
involves this mutation measure we have a
change due to selection acting right so
this is we're looking at the change in
PT acting on some test function so minus
the red change the deflection acting on
current genotypes and then a
normalization due to the average
selection cost because we're thinking we
want Petey to remain as a probability
measure and so we have solution which
well we can write we can write down an
explicit solution basically in terms of
from the funding caps formula which is
when s is is non epistatic when s is
linear this reduces to what you would
expect from the standard story namely
that the we get a plus on random measure
with intensity 1 minus so essentially
which converges to 1 over selective cost
times basically two so to the new of m /
smm and converges exponentially fast to
to that and we also it gives us a series
expansion so in principle we can
calculate everything we want numerically
and and the most qualitatively
interesting result is that so if you
think about what's happening in in the
in the Charles worth story so if you go
too far and ages far enough out the
effect of adding an extra mutation at
that advanced age is going to be very
small rights going to get smaller and
smaller as you go out so the argument is
that in the Charles worth story if you
allow for these nonlinear interactions
in fact there is some finite age at
which the the mortality will go to
infinities you'll get infinite
accumulation of mutate
shins in that model now that is not an
argument for what we think is happening
biologically this is an argument about
mathematical modeling so this is saying
that qualitative the that the simple
nonlinear picture gives qualitatively
wrong results okay because it has to be
thought of as an approximation to a to a
nonlinear picture and the nonlinear
version the nonlinear corrected version
of that gives essentially impossible
results which are qualitatively
different okay so we sorry hey yeah okay
so I want good there aren't in orange
infinitely many mutations around but
actually I won't even I'm not even try
to argue about whether it's biologically
correct some people say this this model
is that we're proposing is ridiculous
because that's obviously not what
happens and we're not claiming that
we've found an argument for what happens
what we found is that this approach to
the you can't do this approach in this
naive way with point masses acting at
this age if in any case you have to
you'll get qualitatively different
results if you take account of the
epistasis so it can't be done in the
linear way which is the way most
modeling in this field have been done
for a long time the original model is
not self consistent yes
so I'm just very quickly going to say
we've got a we have a version where when
we add recombination in a fairly
straightforward way so we imagine you
know one generation at a time having
mutation selection then recombination
where there's some random way of
dividing the genome in half and the
individual pics two random pieces i'm
not going to go into into that here for
arguing why that might or might not be a
good good way of doing it but we crashed
again
all health written warnings and the wall
of death okay well the problem has had
have generally come up when I tried to
skip slide so I won't they won't skip
yeah okay so when we when we add
recombination so well we have a long
argument in in this this memoir which
explains why at least in a certain
scaling regime you you end up with quite
interestingly a dynamical system on on
Ross own random measures on the mutation
space so essentially you've got these
this recombination which mixes things up
and then this potentially epistatic
selection costs which is making things
non pass on but if the if you have small
mutation effects and small it's much
small small mutation rates and small
selective costs then then effectively
it's going to stay close to a dynamical
system on plus on random measures we r
which is defined where the intensity
follows this equation and what this is
the mutation rate so the change in the
intensity is going is the mutation rate
that's picking it up and then minus
essentially
selective cost or what it would be is
the average selective cost of adding
this mutation into a randomly chosen
genotype in the population so yeah so
we're not entirely sure about the the
proper scaling regime but in any case we
know that we have this this convergence
theorem so it stays closed so the one
generation at a time process when
rescaled stays close to this process on
plus on measures and it has some useful
properties so so the when the when we
have actually wrote convex but i think i
meant concave selective cost when the
selective cost is concave as it is in
demographic application then we have
increasing intensity for all all times
so they either go to infinity 4xl wrote
concave convex again and mint concave
right so it's concave is adding an extra
mutation right to mutations together
have less than the effect the cumulative
effect of adding each of them and and so
if there is a measure some measure which
satisfies this equilibrium condition
then since it's increasing it won't go
past that and so it's going to it's
going to converge either to that or some
equilibrium state below it so in fact we
can show convergence to equilibrium in
some interesting cases but also
interesting is that we can find in some
cases that there is no equilibrium
that's to say if we look at something
like the Hamilton Charles worth setting
where their point mass mutation effects
on mortality and a comp
mutation rate across all ages and
constant fertility then it's okay then
it's much worse than the situation we
had in the no recombination setting that
it's not just there some ultimate age at
which survival goes to 0 what happens is
that you know survival goes to zero at
some age and that reduces selective
pressure at a lower age and essentially
the whole mortality curve unravels and
survivorship goes to zero so so I think
there will be agreement that that's
really not what we see well I don't know
how close to zero is it may be you know
anyway so this is then this is
fundamentally different from the no
recombination case okay and we have an
equilibrium condition that we can
compute with I'm not going to go into
the details here because I want to use
my last seven minutes or so to talk to
just to introduce you to a different
very different question I've been
excited about working on in the last
year or two and this this goat cakes a
completely different tack so this is not
talking about random accumulation of
mutation this is asking about what sort
of life history is optimal and I'm
deciding to some notation from aged aged
structured population theory so i'm
going to use i'm going to be thinking of
so i have some age classes which are
thinking of discrete time oh the omega
dropped out here and there was an Omega
somehow turned black yes so we're only
gets the maximum age and for an
individual age x it has a certain
expected number of offspring and
probability of surviving to the next
year and I'm thinking of this as being
in a large population so I'm thinking of
this as being the
actual number of offspring produced by
every individual and I'm thinking of px
as being the fraction of individuals
that survive and so in general the age
distribution will converge to fixed
proportion this is this is well known
and this can be seen from it so in the
mall demographers like to write this in
a matrix notation and right so you've
got the fertility zyk ross the top and
the product survival probabilities on
the sub diagonal and you end up with you
update the population by multiplying by
this matrix and then okay promote her
own frobenius tells us that will get
convergence to a top a distribution
which is given by the cop eigen value
and top eigenvector okay so now what
happens when these these are random
environments well okay I'm not going to
go through this many of you already know
this you essentially get the same story
right if you're if you have a different
set of randomly chosen set of of
fertility and survival rates each year
then you're going to still there's going
to be a top Lyapunov exponent which will
give the growth rate of the population
over time the average growth rate will
be deterministic but there will be a
random distribution of population you
know age structure okay changing from
you okay so I want to apply this to the
problem of diapause so in principle it
seems like rapid reproduction is the key
to population growth and yet many
species will delay the onset of a
maturity okay this is called diapause
and this is sometimes facultative
depending on environmental stress and
sometimes random and so the question is
why is why would this be favored and so
here are some some pictures of chestnut
weevils and monarch butterflies which do
this so the chestnut we
so there are fifty nine percent stay in
the ground defer for a year so and
there's an argument which was first put
forward by Carlin and have been
generalized by by others to essentially
say that well if you have a diagonal
matrix and some sort of off-diagonal
elements and you add a little bit of the
off diagonal things you are always in to
be reducing the spectral radius okay so
that's that's a theorem and this has
been taken with an argument that various
kinds of mixing whether Geographic or or
in in terms of age classes and so on are
will be negative for growth and and this
equivalent in the dipole setting to the
statement that that faster reproduction
is is better so here's the the simple
model for random diapause so we have a d
stage lifestyle cycle and fraction s X
of T I was calling a px before sorry
survive in your tea and at HT the
individuals produce T offspring and then
die and these are to be thought of as
random so if this random matrix so
that's the standard situation and this a
population like this will have gosh I
left off the logs here right so this
should have been expectations of log T
of T expectation of law guess I of T
okay so that will be the the growth rate
and now we add a random diapause a trait
epsilon okay so with probability epsilon
a fraction epsilon will stay and not
move in the you know it will stay in
there 0 class and juvenile state for an
extra year so now for those who are
interested in migration
this is equivalent if you take the you
know a product of D of these you
essentially have a diagonal matrix with
an epsilon rate of migration to other
sites okay and so we can so these are
strongly related question question of
rare daya positive rare migration and
rare diapause is the case where the
growth rates at all sites are equal but
I so I've analyzed both of them so I'll
be interested to know if the result I'm
going to state now is one that's
familiar to people who work on migration
so so first of all here's just an
example in a two-by-two case and the
interesting thing we note is so what I'm
taunting here is the growth rate of the
population where this is the the
fraction of diapause and so the
interesting thing is so at point 05
right you're still pretty high up and
point 01 still really high up and
there's point 0 0 0 1 and we still moved
the growth rate by quite a bit and so
okay so here's the so most of the
benefit comes with a tiny amount of
diapause and so here's the throw here's
the theorem so basically near zero near
zero diapause the the growth rate
behaves like 1 over log epsilon okay so
we have increases like 1 over log
epsilon so it's extremely steep growth
and well here's I'll talk about why if
anyone has it wants to ask about it the
questions and so now the last thing I
want to say is that in the migration
case so that is to say we have diagonal
matrix and then you add on some epsilon
rate of transition to other sites that
the
the modules of continuity at ace of the
rate of increase so it increases
positively by being able to make these
tiny probabilities of migration and it's
like epsilon to the rho where rho is
determined by some combination of the
difference in growth rate between
basically the best and the second best
site the variance or something like the
variance right so more so more variance
means that faster growth the greater
benefit of being able to switch and the
distance from the top best side to the
second best site right in which so it's
at least two to learn from the longest
cycle that starts at zero and ends at
zero and passes through that site so
there are some set of these parameters
for which it would be beneficial even if
you pay a linear penalty to add some
amount of diapause if it's small and
there's some range where it's not
beneficial okay so that's that's it just
a comment in this the issue of diet
halls and optimality of dispersal and
environments there's a huge literature
and ecology about them yeah all right so
Steve Elmer Cornell's who are no bunch
of stuff so I moved them Hamilton in May
so yeah I know babies I just does not
like like a result I see ya yeah this is
this issue of the right the behavior
near near zero dispersal I have a be
seen anything like it but so I can come
back to the question of epistasis I get
it correct that the epistasis can't
prevent the small of death and if some
what kind of ever says is do you need
well it's it's Jared sort of any likely
you're the usual argument mutational
load is that if things you know
positively interact if you have more
more harm from having the two of them
together that somehow reduces mutational
load and that's sort of what we I guess
we see here at least our theorems for
the for unraveling are based on
precisely on and we might call negative
at the stasis that's the concave effect
we're putting getting two mutations
together is is less bad than having
having you know the some of them
separately essentially you know what
what that means is it it kind of lowers
the hurdle to adding extra mutations so
one could assume to have a threshold
life behave
enough of mutations really little and
then like say of course and once you go
beyond the threshold then you probably
die and then of course the stasis will
switch from positive to negative
I mean your resilience against like a
number of mutations well it's so okay so
I think I think what you're saying that
actually relates to to something that
actually was was was very prominent in
actual i think in medawar is original
paper but which hasn't been um hasn't
played much of a part in the discussion
since then well it was either metal
medawar or williams who spoke spoke
about the idea of there being of sort of
modifier mutations so mutate and
mutations out would all that would you
know alter the effect of deleterious me
of other deleterious mutations and
certainly you could imagine they're
doing a benefit to you know essentially
you know accumulating mutations at the
getting mutations or modifications to
the organism that would cause it to
essentially raised the the cost of a
combination of of deleterious mutations
yeah this is an argument that some
people put forward for in particular
people to look at developmental
evolution in terms of the kinds of you
know stringent tests that are that are
placed on for the genetic fitness of
offspring you know eat early in
gestation is that the sort of thing you
are no it was thinking of something very
simple that I mean organisms have all
kinds of mechanisms to offer some
deleterious effects from wherever from
the environment but also for mutation
or you could easily assume let's say the
effect of the first five or ten or
whatever mutations is just buffered
doesn't know anything and then it only
sets in once you get beyond this thread
of course then the point is exactly that
sort of I mean the whole theory of
mutational load given timing tells us
that you know you have a kind of
counterintuitive effect that that
buffering the effects of mutations
likely means you're going to end up with
more of them and ultimately at higher
costs right concave effects right so
buffering essentially increases the
concavity of the effect sure and and so
and of course although most of this
theorizing takes place in context where
we're imagining that there's an
unlimited pool of ability Ernest
mutations of a certain you know level
and shape and if I know I'm at all but
we're still so far as I can see the
theory is very far from being able to
take account of anything like the level
of detail that we're acquiring analysis
yes it is this buffering thing just sort
of like a Frenchman's next like what
happened if you add in do not run away
you know bring some occasion like a
balance
well okay so the problem of trying to
get bring together theories that allow
for positive effects and theories that
allow for negative effects is I think a
very very fraught one and usually
they're treated in completely different
contexts names and methods except maybe
Detroit that is suddenly have some fun
accessibility issues and you'll
eventually build up the back well that
Mets that's it there's an interesting
may be of particular this is interesting
with something we've been thinking about
bit in the in the context of the kinds
of arguments people put forward about
you know kind of island effect so you
there's a population which has assembled
some collection of deleterious mutations
which were once in imbalance and now are
subject to to selection under a
different set of constraints but so
there you think then there's a
particular set of mutations you're
interested in analyzing how they learn
to develop over time but ya want me
you know again suggests that just now
the kinds of data that you might might
want to figure out what what's a
sensible way of thinking about dilla
terrorism mutations starting to come out
from these you know these studies which
can mark up the genome in terms of the
Selective pressure points
good then I think let's thank all the
speakers again